[MUSIC]
Previously, we discussed how to compare
two sequences with each other.
This is pairwise alignment.
And now, let's discuss how to find
multiple sequence alignment.
So how to compare multiple sequences at
once.
Why do we need this?
Statistically significant similarities
between two sequences becomes
more significant if it presents in many
other sequences.
So if you compare a lot of similar
species and you find very conservative
domain in this species,
it is very significant.
While, when you compare these species
pairwise, this conservative sequence may
be not so obvious.
For example, when you align three
A-domains,
which we discussed previously in this
lesson.
You can find many pairwise similarities
between these three
A-domains, but when you're trying to
compare all of them at once, you will
find that similarity, which present
between all of these three sequences, and
which can say you
something about what makes this sequences
behave similarly
in a cell.
So let's generalize pairwise alignment to
multiple alignment.
Previously we used two row matrix for
alignment of two sequences.
Now, when they want to represent alignment
of three sequences, let's use three-row
matrix.
And we will need to design our scoring
function to score alignments with more
conserved columns higher than other ones.
And
our pairwise alignment was a path in a two
dimensional Manhattan grid.
And alignment between three sequences,
actually
it's a path in three dimensional grid.
For example, let's take a look on
alignment of ATGC, AATC, and ATGC.
Here you can see the number of symbols up
to given position
written in a separate vector, and for
first
sequence, it's, it's 0, 1, 1, 2, 3,
4.
Then for a second sequence, it's 0 1 2 3 3
And 0 0 1 2 3 4 for the last sequence.
And we can take columns.
The first column of
this vector.
The second column of this vectors.
And so on and so forth as a points in
three dimensional space.
And our alignment paths will move from
0,0,0 point, which is
source in our three dimensional Manhattan
grid, to 1,1,0, to
1,2,1, and so on and so forth.
And it will finish at the
opposite corner of this three dimensional
grid as
it started, and this opposite corner, we
will also call it, is a
sim similarly to our two dimensional
Manhattan grid.
And two dimensional alignment
during each step we took maximum
of three values, which were vertically,
diagonally,
and horizontally opposite on this
alignment cell.
But in multiple dimension space, you will
have more neighbors for each cell.
For example, for three dimensional
alignment cell, you
will need to take a maximum of seven
values.
And here is dynamic programming equations
for
aligning three sequences.
You will need to find
a maximum among all seven neighbors plus
score of moving from this neighbor to the
current
node.
And how about run
time of such algorithm?
So for three sequences of length n, run
time
is proportional to the number of edges in
this grid.
Similar as before, but the number of edges
now is much larger.
So it's 7 times n cubed, because each of
n cubed node, you'll have seven neighbors
to choose from.
So ky alignment, where you want to find
alignment between k
sequences, will build a k dimensional
Manhattan graph, with n
To the power of k nodes, because it's a
k-dimensional
cube, or k-dimensional rectangle.
And most nodes, except of border ones,
will have 2
to the power of k minus 1 incoming edges.
So overall run time is proportional to the
2 to
the power of k times n to the power of k.
And this is really large, so this
algorithm will work for a small
sequences, small number of sequences, or
many sequences of small length.
But it won't work in a
feasible time for many long sequences.
For example, to find a multiple alignment
of 18 sequences of
lengths 18 each, you will need more time
than the age of universe.
And biologists usually use fast heuristic
algorithms.
They, they don't guarantee the find
optimal solutions, but they guarantee
that this algorithm will finish at a
meaningful time.
Let's discuss few heuristics which will
help us
to find multiple alignment in more
feasible way.
Every multiple alignment in use pairwise
alignment, you can take two rows
by any way you want, and you will get
pairwise alignment of these two
sequences, which is induced from this mul,
multiple alignment.
But can we find multiple alignment from
pairwise alignments?
In generally, no, because given a set of
arbitrary pairwise
alignments, we cannot construct multiple
alignment that induces them.
For example if we have sequences
AAATTT, TTTGGG, and GGGAAA, we have this
three pairwise alignments, which have,
four matches
each, but we cannot construct multiple
alignment of this three sequences
which will induce all these three pairwise
alignment.
But what can we do?
Let's consider profile representation of
multiple alignment.
We had profiles before in this course.
And profile is usually a probability for
each
letter to occur in each column.
So for these sequences, you can see that
first column contains 0 A's, 1 T, 3 C,
and 1 gap.
And probabilities of C
is 0.6.
Probability of T and the gap is 0.2.
So how can we align sequence against
sequence?
You already know this.
This is what Pavel told before in this
lecture.
But can we align sequence against profile?
Or can we align profile against profile?
yes, actually, we can.
So aligning sequence against sequence
requires you to build this Manhattan graph
and write down one sequence
horizontally, and one sequence vertically,
but you can
replace the sequence with a profile and
you can use values
proportional to the values in the profile
to score each
edge in a graph.
Also, you can use profile as a second
sequence.
And you can align these two profiles in
a very similar way that you aligned two
sequences with each other.
But for scoring function, you need to also
consider probabilities, to
have a certain letter in certain
sequence at certain place.
So how we can use this fact
to find multiple alignment.
We can construct simple greedy algorithm.
We will calculate all pairwise alignments
between all sequences.
For example, we have k sequences, as
a start, we will calculate all pairwise
alignments
of these k sequences, which is quadratic
number of, which is proportional to the
quadratic
number of these sequences, and we will
find two closest sequences among all of
them.
And we will join these two sequences into
our file.
After this step, we will have k minus 1
sequences.
Well, actually we will have k minus
two sequences in one profile, but we know
that we
can align profile in the same way as we
align sequences.
And we will iterate, so on each iteration
will reduce number
of sequences and profiles to align between
each other by one.
For example, let's take these four
sequences, GATTCA,
GTCTGA, GATATT, and GTCAGC.
We'll find six pairwise alignments to the
sequences and the best
one is alignment between second and fourth
sequences and
it has score two.
So we will join this
two sequences into one profile and it will
add to our
pool of sequences we will want to align.
And now, we have new set of three
sequences to align, sequence one, which is
originally
sequence one, sequence three, and new
profile.
And we can iterate.
We can construct pairwise alignments
between each
of these three sequences, and find closest
and
join them and so on and so forth, and at
the last step, we will get to
a single profile of multiple alignment.
This greedy algorithm is not optimal.
It may find not optimal solution, but it
will work fast.
And it will work on most of the real world
cases.
So today we learned a lot about sequence
alignment.
We learned how to find pairwise alignment
in quadratic time and linear space.
We learned how to use a find get
analysis, which represent real world
better for biological problems.
We learned how to find global and local
alignments.
We learned how to find multiple alignment
between many sequences at once.
But can you find all similarities between
human, mouse, and rat genomes, given
that these genomes contain billions of
nucleotides?
Can you rapidly find alignments between
human genome and millions of short reads?
Which usually obtain by sequences as
genome.
And are alignment algorithms with
quadratic
time practical when we analyze entire
genomes?
Because as I said mammal
genomes are really large.
And when you try to analyze these genomes,
quadratic time usually not works.
And these questions we will discuss in
future chapters.